[Musique]
merci,
nous avions l'habitude de boire beaucoup et de faire des voyages
et toutes ces choses que
vous savez, nous nous concentrons sur quelque chose
et nous aidons ensuite à construire
nous-mêmes dans cela
[Musique]
Je vais le dire de cette façon, certains de mes gars, vous
savez, ils  Je m'entraînerai jusqu'à deux heures
du matin, tu sais, je joue juste à danser
à la maison et tu sais qu'en faisant ça, tu
leur apprends dans la
rue, à l'extérieur des jeux, tu sais que ça
les empêche de faire d'autres choses qui
autrement seraient possibles.  en difficulté
[Musique]
vous savez, nous avons beaucoup de gens qui ont
beaucoup de bons milieux socio-économiques,
vous savez qu'ils viennent de la rue
pour ainsi dire, donc nous leur donnons l'
opportunité de montrer leur talent maintenant,
ils sont très bons  ça joue tu sais
qu'ils peuvent aller beaucoup plus loin
euh
[Musique]
merci